welcome to the show I voted I've got my
I voted sticker I know Pat has his as
well his is much much bigger than mine
interestingly he's sort of created a
combination of two I voted stickers and
I mean he clearly just has a wave too
much time on his hands and we're gonna
talk about that after the show Pat
believe me okay let's get right into
election predictions and whether I will
once again be very very wrong in my
election predictions I want to just
issue the sort of disclaimer and I know
that there are many people in our
audience who don't need me to issue this
disclaimer they know that I was very
wrong in terms of my 2016 prediction in
the sense that I thought that Hillary
Clinton would win and she didn't win so
why anyone would listen to my
predictions at this point I really don't
know but Pat so far has not had a
terrible track record so we'll get some
of his predictions momentarily so I've
already said and I still believe
generally speaking that Democrats are
going to take the House of
Representatives and that Republicans are
going to keep the Senate this is not an
extraordinarily risky prediction and
it's not an extraordinarily
unpredictable prediction but it still
all has to happen and it's ultimately
going to come down to voter turnout and
now I want to go into a little bit more
detail about exactly what I think the
numbers are going to be we will know
very very soon within hours whether I am
right wrong or I guess somewhere in
between so let's start first with let's
start with the Senate here
I believe that Republicans are likely to
hold the Senate the caveat is that if
turnout is up the way it's been reported
in Texas for Beto O'Rourke and despite
being down in the polls against Ted Cruz
bado
O'Rourke ends up winning that's going to
be a signal that there could be a major
shake-up and a sort of insurgent left
around the country but I believe at this
point in time that the most
statistically likely scenario is
Republicans gained one seat in the
Senate this is not because there's a
lack of a blue wave or no anti-trump
kradic momentum because in the Senate
unlike in the house not every seat is up
every election 1/3 of the Senate is up
every two years for re-election and the
set of Senate seats that are up for
election right now are not particularly
favorable to democrats because democrats
have way more seats to defend I guess
the right way to say it would be and
fewer Republican seats that they even
could take over and then of course when
you look at which Republican seats are
up for re-election
they are mostly very solid red states so
I think that some interesting races
include Indiana where Joe Donnelly has a
pretty good shot of defeating the
Republican Mike Braun Arizona is an
interesting one where Democrat Kyrsten
Sinema is right in there with martha
mcsalley
and then you've got bill Nelson who's
the Democrat in Florida against rick
Scott doing well and then it would be
huge if Jackie Rosen the Democrat in
Nevada Nevada always got to say it that
way it was able to defeat the incumbent
Republican Dean Heller meanwhile
incumbent Democrat John tester in
Montana could actually end up losing his
seat to Republican challenger Matt
Rosendale but testers ahead in the polls
just not really by as much as we would
like to see an incumbent Democrat lead
the day of the election or I looked at
the polls yesterday the day before the
election so that that's the Senate for
me now before I get to the house Pat do
you do you differ with me on in terms of
the Senate I do indeed I'm going bold
here I'm going to predict that Democrats
will take the Senate I could break it
down a little bit if you want
I think bredesen in Tennessee and hide
camp in North Dakota are going to lose
their respective races but the power of
incumbency I think is gonna help quite a
few Democrats I think it's gonna help
tester and Donnelly and Bill Nelson in
Florida and Claire McCaskill in Missouri
and then there are quite a few toss-up
races that I think will go blue because
hey it's a midterm election year and
Republicans are in charge that's help
that tends to help the party that's not
in power so I think that Rosen's going
to win in the
and I think that cinema is going to win
in Arizona that would put everything at
5050 the tiebreaker I think and this is
a big bold prediction beta or orc is
going to defeat Ted Cruz I set it here
first you can quote me tomorrow yeah
listen if I think that what you're
accurately thinking about is that a lot
of these races are within the margin of
error and if turnout is up slightly and
Democratic enthusiasm is higher than
Republican enthusiasm that is unlikely
to be just one race that sort of breaks
from the norm or the trend and you may
well be right your prediction by the way
statistically would also not be a
drastic outlier and that's sort of the
issue when you have so many races within
within the margin of error so Pat says
Democrats take the Senate I say I think
the most likely scenario is that they
don't but believe me I will be here
gladly admitting my mistake if tomorrow
we can tell you that the Democrats have
taken over the Senate then we've got the
house I believe that in the house the
Democrats will take control they will
gain somewhere between 35 and 45 seats
they only need 25 to take over control
of the house so it really shouldn't be
closed unless the polls are not so much
very wrong but just if everything within
the margin of error goes for Republicans
Democrats have gerrymandering and voter
suppression working against them but as
Pat mentioned historically the party
that wins the White House loses in the
next midterms didn't happen with George
W Bush in 2002 sort of unique
circumstances it usually does and big
new voter registration numbers for
Democrats
do you agree on House Pat I do agree on
house I think Democrats will take the
house I think that's a much more
surefire prediction some races to look
at how about Steve King versus JD
Shelton I really hope that Shelton can
pull it off there that would be huge I
really hope JD Shelton replaces Steve
King so then let's talk about governor's
races right now we have 33 Republican
governors 16 Democratic governors one
independent Bill Walker in Alaska in the
end if Democrats gain it will be one or
two okay
I think Andrew Gilliam has a really
great shot in Florida to turn that
governor's mansion blue Iowa could go
blue Wisconsin could switch to blue
Republicans likely are going to take
Alaska from the independent and that
will go red Illinois has a Republican
incumbent and will almost certainly go
blue and beyond that it's gonna be
mostly the same party remaining in
control so that's like a plus one or a
plus two for Democrats if things go
roughly as expected so is this enough
for what right what are we looking to
have happen in the house if Democrats
take over that means actual
investigations into more than just Trump
into all of the corruption that we've
seen so far it means more control over
spending it means more control over
taxes it means being able to force some
negotiation to get things done which
simply isn't necessary for Republicans
to concede when they control everything
winning the house probably changes the
tenor of the 2020 election which is
about to start by the way and I'm told
by some people very close to some of the
bigger potential Democratic candidates
that we could see announcements very
early in 2019 about the 2020
presidential race so what we need to be
worried about is the 2016 election
repeating which means you gotta go vote
you got to go vote every single one of
you needs to vote I voted if you haven't
voted yet depending on when you're
listening to this you can still go vote
and I encourage you to do that